food banks are struggling to meet a
surging demand with a record number of
Americans out of work thousands of
people are lining up outside
distribution centers all across this
country just to feed their families
Janet shamlian visited the biggest food
bank in the United States and shows us
why food supply is not their most urgent
concern the Houston Food Bank is
America's largest in a normal year it
says it gives out 80 million pounds of
food how much have you seen demand
increase in recent weeks we're now
averaging close to a million pounds a
day of actual distribution here and
we're still not meeting the need CEO
Brian Green says demand is up 150
percent from just two months ago the
cavernous 135 thousand square foot
facility trucks food to pantries and
charitable groups in 18 counties there's
desperation they haven't seen here
before with limits they haven't had to
adhere to it's being able to keep up
with the labor is actually what our
biggest problem is the food bank was
built to handle a thousand volunteers
only 150 can be in the building to
comply with social distancing the
warehouse is brimming with produce right
now these crates hold thousands of
cucumbers donated by a farm in a
different time they would have been sold
to restaurants
oh it's unprecedented demand and a
smaller workforce Green is concerned
about giving less to the community as
time goes on at what's called a super
site distribution on Monday gridlock for
miles as thousands tried to reach the
giveaway churches and the food bank
delivered enough for 75 hundred families
to receive 100 pounds of food each
volunteers serving 1,200 cars an hour
for now the food that I'm getting from
different parts do you know if another
side is not enough this Food Bank is
more customed to emergencies like
hurricanes where the need usually
subsides in weeks with the pandemic
there is no end date we're gonna keep
trying we're gonna keep giving as much
assistance as we can but the level of
need what's going on is just so much
bigger than what we're able to do
and we're here in the Houston Food Bank
this morning we're in their kitchen
where they are cranking it out 14 to 15
thousand meals will be made here today
but they can't do right now they say is
something that's very important to them
usually when they deliver food or people
pick up food they chat with them they
have that conversation ask how they're
doing but in a time of social distancing
it's very much of a sterile delivery at
a time when people are really craving
that human connection
yeah there's food and then there's food
for the Soul Janet and both are very
important appreciate that report